I have to tell you wait I have to tell
you this before I leave you I was so
excited to see you last night I was like
in a frenzy and I was running around
with my cats and I didn't know what to
do and so I tattooed a C on my foot you
tattooed I'm like where's the C right
there oh my god you tattooed this is a
real tattoo of a C and that's for me on
your foot my foots shaking cause it's an
awkward position I thought you were
trembling at my touch
[Applause]
you're just gonna add something else to
that you just put a C and that's a very
little commitment you can just add
something later on why don't you meet a
guy named Chris or Carlos what you can
add that later on or I really like
Benedict Cumberbatch and then suddenly
it's not a C for Conan no I did it last
night for you and my assistant who has
no tattoos she's like the sweetest
little angel I was like come here and I
chased her down and gave her one too
you've made your chest your assistant
get a tattoo of a C oh oh oh that's okay
then that's the extent of my narcissism
wait a C for me how old is she 14 I
don't care as long as it's for me that's
fantastic yeah just ok rising star
you're on a network television show I
have a hard time picturing you on a
network television show they've got
rules they must be telling you all the
time Kesha don't say this yes you can't
wear that you have no idea I do the
first show my vagina almost fell out it
was like literally a quarter of an inch
away from like falling out it's not
something that can fall out walling out
doesn't fall out I think you mean it
might have been revealed yeah it doesn't
a guy fall out yeah no such thing as
like
yeah there goes the old vagina Oh
[Laughter]
anyways enough about my vagina I think
they'd never is gonna be very pleased
with this they get really mad at me
because I say the bad words and then
they go to dead air so it's not like a
beep it just goes to nothing and they
like shoot a picture of the ground
so I'll them say like [ __ ] oh yeah this
is dead air what why did this show the
test ground for everything we can't do
that anyplace respectable let's go over
to Conan penises are flopping badges are
flying around
it's not
[Applause]
I like it candy Lexy but you're in the
laboratory of Filth and I hear a perv
you